now there comes a time in every girl's
life where we grow the fuck up and
become women and I feel like one of the
main things that we have to confront as
we get older is sexuality are we sexy MA
am i sexy this does one have to feel
sexy to be sexy and and do I have to try
to be sexy or can I just like wake up
one day and I'm sexy today yeah I mean
fuck beautiful cuz we're all beautiful
in our own unique way yes you are but
sexy is hard and weird I have never felt
sexy and comfortable at the same time
it's just awesome babe let me see no no
it's it's the thought that counts I've
had pole dancing classes on my list for
forever simply because I want to get
over this feeling that when I'm naked
I'm an alien
what are you it's hard it does not feel
natural fuck everything my mom told me
liar I feel like sexy is something I
have to actively work towards to achieve
a master that shit's not pre-installed I
mean come on coz cute
nailed it pretty okay yeah maybe on a
good day maybe soon I don't know sexy
what is this but don't misunderstand me
I don't want to come across as sexy to
other people because that's subjective I
don't have any fucking control over what
you think I want to be sexy to me at
least sometimes at least what I'm trying
to be or what I want to be cuz let's
face it I mean as an Asian pursuing
acting sooner or later when I grow out
of this middle school esque face I'm
gonna have to go out for a role that
requires me to be a sexy pants and if I
don't believe it who will who else I
just farted
I'm so sorry that is not sexy I just
farted in the middle of a rant about
being sexy no wonder you have no self
esteem about this area because you are
just a gas machine apparently